walk him to this video I'm playing at
our tactical from Spain let's see I'm
going for kings in yen let's see
classical mean line yep amazingly
popular on all levels hmm yeah I really
don't know 85 there's all kinds of ideas
this is how I sometimes played it back
when I was regularly employing the Kings
Indian so shouldn't be terribly bad
maybe it is ok a v6 roque one takes on
b6
okay i'm really not sure maybe the Queen
side is just too weak could mean a seven
or something okay but now i got bishop
age six and this is quite nice possibly
getting this check on a three or
sometimes threatening to take
technically but ok Jesus certainly a
nice that I get this in the question is
how to continue and takes maybe we can
maybe we capture with the palm or g5
even not sure I don't want to I spent
too much time of course the c4 but I
have ideas with 94 and others 93 is also
a funny way to to get get something
going here k bishop here take care okay
let's do this and also 93 in the
pollution
mmm very complicated getting this in
okay Majesty I just want to just play
that hard too hard to figure out what
what's really the best maybe this night
only three is getting stranded this can
happen
no it's not it's not so easy it's always
nice see to Islam yeah I've kept tonight
see 20 I can just take or queen a5 also
move takes Bishop takes this is
retaining Queen 85 maybe it's an active
continuation yeah black should be okay
yeah bring don't think am I can be in
any serious trolley with this active
pieces
it's not so easy to make a move here for
four white okay Bishop here look at 42 d
4 is also quite attractive yeah maybe
of course I would love to play rook h4
takes h2 queen age for checkmate this is
the the kind of stuff you want to do but
probably probably not so easy to
accomplish
maybe 90 for him Skippy ms Bishop before
fe for rookie 40 Kames not doing
anything like that ok let's just
approach here intending king queen 24
look H to mate yeah that's it's a very
obvious thing but let's try that anyway
if it takes I can take with the pawn and
I have a very dangerous passer so not
not terrible anyway yeah ok so Brooke
edge for this a very very crude trick or
something else hmm
yeah that's so let's be crude there's
also Bishop f4 and and things like that
in the mix check so it's not just a
stupid one move trick check okay can go
here ok so now if I take it Queen edge
for this Queen age three so but I have
this move as well intended Queen takes
g3 and I'm not quite sure what he does
against it maybe he has some some count
to play with unpossible Queen f8 but I
don't really think it is working like
Quincy eight for example Queen g3 Queen
fa check yeah but no I know I get in
this chair this idea checkmate yeah
sometimes the simple ideas really work
at the end I'm not quite sure if this
was really good good play but black is
very active so it's not it's not not bad
probably you know now we get serious
counter-plan maybe I should just take
but I was 220 fascinated by this idea
okay white is much better now because of
94 okay yeah this is this is the big
problem okay hmm now the problem is I
cannot really take if you look at this
check and now I'm the one
being in big trouble yeah this was what
puteri good check and even here this is
much better only this is losing we need
six losses it can play still mighty form
and be a be much better yeah I don't
really have this this direct kind of a
tech that I was hoping for this however
is this is flat-out losing it he's in
the major yeah he was so obviously
irritated so I should I should play it
differently maybe look fo I still okay
but starting around here there I should
probably select some some other
continuation with the two active bishops
and the active pieces of black should be
fine okay thanks for watching